his crash bandicoot 4 gonna have
microtransactions is cyberpunk gonna
have the wall running is Xbox actually
gonna have a live event this month we
have the answers to those questions in
today's safe State for Wednesday July
1st
I'm current vina welcome we live in a
time where we must ask with every new
game does it have microtransactions and
for crash bandicoot 4 the answer is no
it doesn't but it's a reasonable thing
to ask speculation arose when Microsoft
Store listing for the game said offers
in-app purchases developer toy store
Bob's took the twitter to clear the
whole thing up saying quote we're seeing
confusion about micro transactions in
crash bandicoot 4 and want to be crystal
clear there are no micro transactions in
crash 4 as a bonus the totally tubular
skins are included in all digital
versions of the games now that that's
all cleared up we have an interview with
the game's producer that you should
totally check out the link to it will be
in the description below cyberpunk 2077
from the looks of it lets you do a lot
of things you can go through the entire
game without killing somebody you can
also like look through people's minds
and rewind and fast-forward stuff you
can customize your genitals but one
thing the game won't let you do is wall
run wall running was originally a thing
the level designer max pairs told game
reactor that it was cut for design
reasons but still he mentioned the game
will offer players a lot of flexibility
with how they move through the world so
don't know that's a deal breaker for you
but thought you should know we have a
ton of cyberpunk 2077 coverage including
a hands-on impression with a game on our
website and in YouTube and you know
where to find it okay so first Xbox was
going to do monthly events leading up to
the launch of the Xbox series X and then
they decided not to do one in June but
they are doing one this month still on
July 23rd this was reported by Jeff
Grubb of entropy and as planned before
this event will prominently focus on
first party titles one of them being
Halo Infinite we're also supposed to be
seeing something from Forza horizon
developer playground games and
something from a new studio the
initiative there's rumors swirling
around that playground games is working
on a new fable and then other rumors
that the initiative are working on a new
perfect dark entry lots of rumors I know
but hopefully it will beginning answers
for these questions this month on July
23rd okay this is that moment when I
talk about play for all that thing that
we here at GameSpot are doing a
multi-week wonderful videogame event
where every single day from 12 p.m. to 2
p.m. Pt we're hosting a charity stream
with a bunch of sweet special guests
raising money for black lives matter and
people fighting on the front line of
Kovan 19 relief tomorrow Thursday July
2nd we're doing a charity stream with
super eyepatch wolf and then on Friday
we're gonna have people make games as
Chris Pratt and then accompanying these
live streams we have a bunch of
exclusive content interviews like the
crash bandicoot one I also just did an
interview with the developers of death
loop you should give it all watch
because I'm excited about it that game
and that I did that I interviewed them
that's cool anyways that's it for today
you can of course find out about that
and a whole bunch of other stuff at
gamespot.com I'm Curtin Davina thank you
for being here
stay cool give thumbs up all that jazz
you know the drill
alright see you later
[Music]
you
[Music]